The
next excerpt is taken from original tape W.
twenty.
Your kids or leaders Your Let's continue the program.
You know the hard
times
of my phone comes from
Bell phones are
controlling the covered
writing of
mine with showing the
room numbers your no
other revenue
from Glen Ridge brings it go for or been
assumed from around the gun machine Margrove No no but Grand Junction then the
road from Grand Junction up from the country's all on the side of the river just a
little to come
over fifty look for them to age thirty Grand Junction for their blood
from Brenda back from the director run
no sign of them during the dark and no one know the back good hardly an early day.
So you can still see it on Mt
Garfield just around Mt Garfield on your way out of town you can still see a
very old Rose Bowl rewrote the other side of the Polish faded
Yes yes you can still
hear the realtor took them are almost about over but those places where you
are still freezing cold
room right. That's the road you have traveling for your travel fee for
the gun from the from Room Chris Kaman rug and take a long ways to
come Grand Junction and get back in from the area of debate you're talking new
very appropriate remedy to drown or
three hundred five mile
mile of the rim of during the
day when much running
Granger What do you remember about the stories in Grand Junction what was there at that
early
period. The early days of a just one story which was that
I would know the name of Percival build a
luxury
of joining member where it used to stand in relation I don't
know probably I've never there in
order to rid of the beast. When you're
growing you know
of the you never did you ever go to the to the old
store during the rainy trips to the altar What's the first part of Grand Junction that you
remember room remembered too much about about a river when most tried to
put me in the sidewalk or street
sir blacktop an overall good.
You know on some that is but noone
of us for blood talk or pavement or something under a
member of stoner come down another feller and I rushed
from horses to
sell
of so you were
older man or woman working
two
of you to see if there's
overlap for a job
of friends can count on the good grown crowd or the end
of the room instead of if you can ride the horses I give you
the ride I'll give you a
job and he did
have one for the summer
camp as they're about to read them and other
four mornings. Jimmy packs out on a horse
a good thirty thirty
five miles to get the from
where a camper uses to choose from
winter clothes of in September
of a looming when is
good for your good night.
Oh sure I can. And you
don't work except for can render of a
bucket term.
Of honor and remember her nine other subtle
rushes in an unpleasant or drop the golden
or sudden sign your name or plants is you
know.
Well it's rumored or
drink rangelands you know we're Mr.
Yes and
wish we were there towards me Korean P.M.'s country
where you go by the way to go down. Up Yanks
groups of guns seven
read
on the phone no I didn't.
No I didn't you did you break these horses for him. Did you train
them for love book club
servants broke a lot of horses firm of
us of the land is a rodents cradle
raised horses they were wild Bronco horses. I used to just
love
of these. Some of their
horses they're rounding up are these still some of the same type of
horse purchase Richard.
Railroad neither horses than those who didn't raise many settlers but the my
mother horse somebody of erosion
and. No proportions of mother father
and her own former
producer that's that's a pretty heavy thing there be
a pretty important job and one that not everybody
did they didn't. They didn't have a brother
do that mean you got more pay than the rest of us. Yes I did
you just really not remember a marriage. Forty dollars a month is their
right to another's top wages.
We're going very many got over thirty third fronts.
Do you ever ride for the rodeo do any of that or was
it strictly work in the district or work I didn't have time to really run
an inroad there were rodeo no surprise
of anything today if there would have been rodeo he
would have liked to have done then you know they
just do you remember the first rodeo The two do you recall the first rodeo
that you were all that for one landed the one claimed in the moment to Mark Bowden If you or
she
is and did you participate. No No
It's why
would I want to Glenn would run climb the ctor rodeo up there. I didn't
ride and several of the voyage conferences their one leader ride
and what I did in Germany just
to see the city have more faith in yourself and
man. Do you remember the hell stick you grew up
in what was it
like it's your house one room
and it's three rooms are this normal of all
the streets has more journalists let
them
have the floor was
what for Julian Jansen
of home plays with was raised. Reed
moved away
from there and live in below there on a big pleasure long
car trips and they build a
big reservoir of love of that verb
form spring. It's in and never left my mother a chicken and wash
or buildings or a foreigner up or prays it's she
didn't have a chicken drownded or homes and
of
riches of no more the been appearing tournaments of them
were from the brink of. Groom
and Reid moved out of the house for relived a point of the hill.
It's run by knowledge. Crown. It didn't wash of the house or a but it
washed all the cruel trick mother's chickens in
their home. Never going to see missing like never enough
to cry on or just over
things when who did who did your father tell was the government.
Who was in charge of that
damn rule or the farmers really milk. Farmers
own and
their owners. No the government didn't know enough to do with
that didn't have any insurance in those re how to engineer
the bills put in those head gates were
supposed from the crews got a high rise to take care of all over but he wouldn't take care of a third
of the heads Bill
raised them as a new dam in a just God grant and they
can draw the water off. She just a little like
us were there any other families in that area or were
you how it was in the day ran her own
had her done herding of
other river because of its spread out over the valley and over fields
in the creek her reservoir water never heard and wrote ill mother to up
some fences
or pleading have insurance or anything. Dave did you
say when you had to suffer the whole lot of danger for
the little more deadly than thirty acres of places and it's rather
green of the saved love of the potatoes
the DIDN'T large current wave it's got a lot of grain to just
green roll the green that's. When you
were writing you were out all winter long is that
right. Farm homes
losing one hundred day with a pretty hard winners. Talk to remember it
was really called
the crew of your first time or
two probably really right. You're not exaggerating
what happened did you get stranded somewhere
or just maybe you should
learn form of.
Of course if you didn't have a good warm
cozy my hands are
free of
of
pressure but just from cheerful homes you can dress
form
of motion a pretty tough
girl most
of the few times I don't know how to going to
make
working for my nephew appear four years
ago on the mountain. Really
job
searches
for the didn't never in circulation
is done
but God is our cause them.
No blood clot OK. But it affected them they were
very
sensitive strike. Come home you're not been your car.
The second of the fire for
adults never is a nurse. For us
from here coming by undressing the side for me.
She come
that morning. Completely gone.
I'll just pass through. So she can have the Dr
the shed over here in his room and try to get around the
spin room tonight if you
haven't. Most of them should really be alive. If we can get
something done for him for
them so he comes off privilege then they took me over there.
To convene a new dress for me right to St
Mary's or center over to his doctor
then through the doctors.
You're no doctor come for heard of
and I've had. Your neighbor
as a grill the Gurnet take care of Lego
you mustn't said no you're not a number of years later I
know better
than the
real you try to operate. They operate in a
troop of I took a blood. Time Around five and I
think for heaven's sake that's a you're pretty lucky.
So then I laid there to really heard from
her many times I mean a very
real oh well you got a lot of rest and pretty good
you know her my
bills little bit over eight thousand a week.
Kind
of tough on the
budget Yeah
those modern conveniences
now most are
with them when you're
just well before the dry come off
just
as I said gentleman got sort of paid and paid them.
Jim I
remember just they go they have that for about
three dollars a person Medicare paid fumes.
Well go for should get me more
stories.